I want to start by saying first
congratulations on the show I cannot
wait I've seen the first three episodes
I cannot wait to watch more one of the
things that early on there was a lot of
talk with the Apple shows that they were
going to be very family-friendly and
it's all PG and I can assure people with
this up with this show that this is a
rated R show this is for you know I
would say there's more for adults can
you sort of talk about that aspect that
it's not just aimed at you know this has
more to it you know I would say not
quite are but it would certainly be you
know over over ten but life is that way
so I don't think we're presenting
anything that life doesn't give and
sometimes young children are having to
deal with life and it is interestingly
enough it is absolutely family oriented
because it it's about family all kind of
things happen in family and so we are
looking at in a realistic way especially
when family has survived an apocalyptic
event and it with that that far into the
future so I think you can watch it
certainly with you know you know 11-year
olds who have who you don't hide things
from for both of you one of the things
that really struck me for the show is
the level of production design the world
building it's tremendous can you sort of
talk about that aspect of the show and
what it was like walking on set for the
first time it was beautiful my first day
on set was outside of the cave with the
rain falling and just being in the
elements with my tribe behind me in
Paris in the front and it was really
just being on the land with the people
there was a kind of instinctual sense
that there is something right about it
and natural about it and that's what I
really loved about the show is that it's
this return to the land and to really
the bare bones of human nature and how
we interact with each other
Steven Knight's imagination
is limitless and it is explosive and
creative it took the same kind of artist
to bring that a to of the physicality
and so when I first saw our structures I
practically wept it was I couldn't
believe how beautiful are our dwellings
were and then we we shooting it for like
two days and they pare it down and then
we'd go somewhere and they'd make
something even more beautiful that was
you know Caroline Hanina and ha Nina and
Trish Somerville our customer they all
worked nico Lapage they all worked very
closely with with Steven and with
Francis it was one team really making
that world come to life so that when we
stepped into it you know I was like that
was constantly saying I can't believe
this I can't believe I was too excited
every day when they brought us something
else
a to love costume beautiful I also
walking onto set every day watching them
like tape I was like we're only here for
four days and it's like a whole village
it's so beautiful and big and like
detail-oriented like all of the little
things that we without sight needs to
navigate through our world and I was
thinking there's so much fear that
people will never see there's like no TV
without nails it was lashed together
yeah it would withstand hurricanes
exactly and our tribe the alchemy is
weaving tribe so ropes and and like
twine and things those are that's from
our environment and it's that's kind of
the basis of our tribe so one of the
things that I think little things that I
really enjoyed were the way messages are
passed with the rope you know the the
lettering and it just was so deep and
thought-out see when you were billed
because you're your viewers are watching
it if you establish a world you have to
be true to that world down to the nth
degree and I
production designers and our writers
they that's that's the way it had to be
you know it but it was challenging but
that's why you get into it is to be able
to focus that way completely I heard
there was a boot camp and I would
imagine sometimes you hear about actors
with boot camps and you you know is it
really necessary level bluff but I would
imagine with this one this was very
necessary to learn how to walk to learn
what it would be like without sight can
you sort of talk about the experience of
getting ready for the roles well you
know what I once did a play in several
Croatian back years ago I had three and
a half weeks to learn my script I didn't
speak the language but I was on stage I
learned phonetically what to do so it
would be as if me saying oh I'll be in
that play blast and not speaking a lick
of surface of the Havas key so we could
not come to this work to try to tell
this story with the predicament that
mankind finds itself in six hundred
years in the future if we did not do I
would even call it a boot camp that
sounds like a fitness thing I would call
it no people call it that but I would
call this more of an introduction into
the possibility of a language without
without sight as we know it mm-hmm
completely necessary it was it was
absolutely and I I'm really grateful for
this space that that friend francis
lawrence asked for this time before we
started shooting so that we could get to
know this world and the characters and
the way that we moved about the space
before we even got on to the camera and
that's what i think is so special about
the show is that it feels authentic in
that way what we mainly discovered was a
respect yeah
for people who move about in the world
without vision as we know it as we talk
about it i have to stop there again
congratulations I cannot wait to finish
up the season oh absolutely
I've only seen three as well